without their support president Maduro
could quickly lose his grip on power the
military parade was held to commemorate
Independence Day but it also highlighted
that most in the Armed Forces still
seemed to back Venezuela's embattled
president Maduro used the festivities to
address the opposition saying dialogue
is the way to end Venezuela's political
crisis stop with the conspiracies stop
with the plots stop with the evil stop
with the plans to destabilize and harm
Venezuela Venezuela wants peace and work
and that's why I repeat my call for
national dialogue meanwhile opposition
leader Juan Guido was sending a defiant
message with his own rally
whydo already ruled out further dialogue
with maderos government earlier this
week he cited recent UN reports
implicating Venezuela's security
apparatus in thousands of extrajudicial
killings as well as torture and other
rights violations the UN said it clearly
Venezuela now lives in a dictatorship
but let the world see that - we have not
surrendered nor are we going to
surrender to any dictatorship we are
going to continue in the streets
[Applause]
but as the fight for control of
Venezuela drags on millions are caught
in the middle the political turmoil is
accompanied by an economic crisis that's
left people short of basic goods and
desperate for change we're joined now by
DW journalist Johan Ramirez who's
reported extensively on Venezuela Johan
we just saw in that report
Maduro talking about the possibility of
of talks with the opposition which the
opposition rejects do we see the
opposition and the leadership coming
together for talks anytime soon this is
the neverending story in Venezuela we
have two completely different versions
on one side Maduro is saying yes this
week we're going to have a second round
of talks and if on the other hand we
have y doce no way we're not going to
talk with the dictatorship so what is
going to happen we will see it in the
net in the days to come but what I think
is that maybe this kind of talks in
Norway could be maybe the last chance
for Venezuela to get peacefully out of
this crisis I mean we have seen months
of protests in the streets we have a
huge international pressure we have US
sanctions we have lot of things done but
the Rose is still there and sometimes a
stronger and stronger so what is the way
to get out of this this ayah has been
calling for months they are me to step
aside aside from a drone to all house -
Maduro so it's like we are wishing a
military coup that will be catastrophic
for Venezuela for the region so maybe
Norway is the last chance to get out
peacefully it's a strange situation I
mean it's been months obviously since
one Guido
declared himself the interim president
but he's still not in power even as we
speak now why not and will it ever
happen yeah the answer we saw it
yesterday why though we went out to the
streets with the people a Maduro had a
military parade so the answer is because
but why doe doesn't have know yet the
military support but the message was
clear yesterday
I mean Maduro is going through a
catastrophic situation 130,000 percent
of inflation
according to his own numbers incredible
yeah by the end of the year according to
the International Monetary Fund we're
gonna have ten millions percent of
inflation and 43 percent of unemployment
so it's gonna be catastrophic but he's
still there why because he has the
weapons and yesterday this military
parade was the message I mean we
certainly still there for now but as you
know this week the UN presented a report
that accused President murderous
security forces of torture and
extrajudicial killings in 2018 do you
think this report this report will have
any impact on Venezuela I think we will
have in Venice for that it gives a new
key element to why the speech I mean he
is not just the opposition on the
National Assembly who is denouncing this
is a huge institution international
institution United Nations who is saying
okay look we have torturing Venezuela
they're denouncing hundreds of arbitrary
detentions almost 7,000 extrajudicial
killings since 2018 there these are
numbers that when we see this number we
think about the dictatorship that Latin
America in the 70s and 80s so it gives
why the new strength but we cannot
forget that the situation it was in
Venezuela hasn't changed one can say yes
but yesterday there were less people in
the streets supporting white oh yeah of
course because the situation hasn't
changed so the priorities of people is
now honestly democracy and free
elections or freedom for political
prisoners is every single day finding
something to eat and something some
medical medicines you're on Ramirez
thank you so much for that thank you